going to talk about now as we always do
in the second hour of the program at the
very top superlatives go ahead you leave
this time today
i will and i'm going to start with uh
the welcome back mccaffrey award
christian mccaffrey
back and and did not miss a beat in
helping the carolina panthers put a
scare into the kansas city chiefs it's
something i said last night and i talked
about this to travis kelsey after the
game look the chiefs are always going to
take the absolute best that every team
they face
has to muster because the chiefs are the
measuring stick the chiefs are the
ultimate measuring stick right now in
the nfl if you can just play close to
the chiefs if you could somehow beat
them that's a huge huge deal
so every week no matter who the opponent
is the chiefs have to be ready for the
onslaught and it seems like the chiefs
themselves get locked in for certain
great opponents yeah but for the
run-of-the-mill teams they they just
they kind of sleepwalk at times
regardless mccaffrey back
with 100 yards from scrimmage again
actually 151 total 18 rushes for 69
yards and a touchdown 10 catches on 10
targets for 82 yards and a touchdown
this is why you get 16 million a year
the guy's basically a receiver and a
running back in the same body it was
refreshing to see him come back and have
a big day after missing seven weeks with
a high ankle sprain but i will say this
and you spotted it when it happened
chris
late in the game he took a hit at the
sideline
and he wasn't right right it was either
collarbone or shoulder he's on the
sideline and he's kind of doing this he
came back for a play
after the game matt rule didn't have any
update mccaffrey didn't meet with
reporters because of the pandemic you
know and hey why wouldn't you meet with
reporters your first game back in seven
weeks why isn't he one of the guys that
they put out there to have the zoom
video conference with reporters i just
feel like this is one of those where
we we have to
kind of watch it a little bit see there
may be something there and i'll give you
another reason why i poked around last
night with usually some reliable and
helpful and cooperative sources that are
in position to know a little bit about
this and i got crickets oh and sometimes
that's usually sometimes those yeah
sometimes those crickets mean
something's going on
yes right yes yeah but but still
hey
if yesterday was the only time we see
him again and i'm not saying it is
but congratulations mccaffrey's back and
uh even though the panthers lost another
one this is a team that has a very
bright future teddy bridgewater is
awesome mccaffrey is awesome and matt
rule has done a great job rebuilding
this team on the fly yeah i mean they're
just they they have the appropriate game
plan every week i mean there's never a
game where they come out and you just go
what are they doing what were they
thinking how stupid was that wow they
don't seem ready to play today i mean
matt rule has them ready to play every
week you know teddy bridgewater played
well yesterday yeah like you said
mccaffrey hey forget that he's a
talented runner it is it's all the
passing game let alone the other weapons
you have to match up with i mean hey
listen we talk about the chiefs weapons
and i'll talk about them here in a
second but mccaffrey robbie anderson
curtis samuel dj moore damn that's up
there with anybody in football i mean
that's it's anybody
and you know the only thing they don't
have there is just an electric big-time
quarterback but teddy bridgewater still
damn good he really is and that's where
mccaffrey really helps out bridgewater
because bridgewater is not a throw the
ball down the field let me flip field
position with one throw type of guy
mccaffrey five four run after the catch
that's teddy bridgewater's game but i
think to me more than anything you know
and again hey it's like another game the
chiefs win yeah he throws her four
touchdowns and no interceptions kelsey
100 yards receiving tyreek hill 100
yards receiving but so what like they
were not on their a game like you said
yesterday it was more like a b-minus
game and it's not even like it's be my
you know it was everything it was sloppy
across the way i mean letting up the
fake punt you know when they kind of
have a chance to get momentum back some
bad penalties and some bad moments chris
jones had one where they're going to get
off the field and he gets an unnecessary
roughness call and goes crazy for a
second there so yeah we just we've seen
this from the chiefs just you i mean
you're all over it they're just not
buckled in all the time and and the the
panthers are one of those teams that
we've seen you can't take them lightly
they're going to play everybody close uh
that was a fun game to watch
and you know chiefs are now on their buy
chief scenario on their buy they have
the raiders on sunday night football in
las vegas when they come back and and
kelsey told me i don't plan on losing
any more or many more this year and they
are locked
they may have been caught flat-footed
against the raiders the last time they
are going to be determined to come out
of this bye week and we know how good
andy reid coach teams are when you give
them extra time to prepare they're going
to be determined to beat the raiders so
you know what's going to happen we're
all going to pick the chiefs the raiders
are going to win and then all the
raiders social media accounts are going
to rub our faces in it that's two weeks
from today yeah future predictions nah
it won't happen if we're all going to
pick the chiefs the chiefs won't be
asleep this time against the raiders
they won't i know i won't i won't buy
that they'll be ready to go because of
that loss and they'll be a little angry
about it chiefs hey you know you've said
it and it's real
you know they are the super bowl champs
they are the team that everybody wants
to watch and see the highlights and see
what patrick mahomes does i mean they
are that team so they get the best shot
from everybody and yeah i think what's
scary is
they don't play their best football and
they come down to the level of opponents
but they still win games and here they
are where you can really look at them
and go
they've only played like maybe two a
games this year but here they are one
loss and setting themselves up and
that's what's scary i mean it really is
because you just go whoa if they like
get it all together here how damn good
are they gonna be and uh that that's
what's awesome about kansas city
what else they play their best games
against the best teams i do that's
what's scary about the postseason they
know when to show up at the right time
all right what's your first one well
i'll give the bounce back award i'm
gonna go there with the ravens like just
everything about them the way they
played that football game against the
colts you know really i want to give
credit to lamar jackson the stats
anything like that are not going to show
how good he was in this football game
you know again i was critical last week
of some of his throwing and everything
they do
but
you know here we are their defense makes
a few plays but in the second half they
weren't able just to rely on overpower
run game and he was really
a pocket quarterback in the second half
of the football game was smart
understood what kind of game he was in
wasn't going to take a chance and go oh
let me you know take a chance here and
try to make some spectacular play and
you know let the colts defense who's
awesome you know kind of jump start
their team with the turnover but of
course we know the running is special
but the 10 you look at this 10 for ned
119 you know yards a rushing td
you know on three of their five
possessions there in the second half
that was him being smart accurate throws
right on the money letting receivers run
do that i thought that was big for him
it really was it's not gonna get a lot
of headlines but i think it's gonna be
one thing where again they're gonna go
okay here's another level with the step
the step up and the pass game looks
pretty good and then of course that
defense just
started to steamroll there in the second
half i mean that game was fascinating
and i think that turnover was really the
the big aspect of the game that we
probably need to talk about for a second
you mean the wait are you talking about
the
chris clark the christmas one rivers are
the or the interception yeah the the
well i want to go the interception the
chris clark won just to hit on that i
think was important because the colts
were totally controlling the game they
went down the field and scored a
touchdown and they were going down the
field again to where you were going whoa
they're going to go up 14 nothing here
at the very least it looked like 10
nothing they got that big play but the
marcus peters interception
that i'm sorry i still can't
sit here and tell you that i think he
caught that football you know i i don't
wha what's your final say on that mic
after watching highlights and seen it a
bunch of times
back to the chuck clark play though it
was great because even though i'm in
west virginia this year due to the
pandemic i have a live link into the
viewing room and chris is saying as the
play is happening man the colts are
really putting it to him the ravens just
don't have anything today and the next
thing you know there goes chuck clark
the other way with the football jumping
over it was scoring a touchdown it was
on point it happened at that moment at
that as it unfolded he was saying it all
right the marcus peters interception
when i saw it the first time i thought
what the hell there's no way that is a
catch
but then when you watch it slowly
and and again i don't know if that makes
it clear and obvious the 50 drunks in a
bar standard under that standard it
wasn't an interception but if we are
going to utilize the technology and look
at it frame by frame and look at the two
key factors which is possession of the
football and he had it in both hands we
saw a catch recently ruled where a guy
never put a second hand on it they gave
the guy a one-handed catch exclusive
one-handed catch and they called that
possession
um he had the ball in both hands long
enough for three feet to hit the ball
started to wobble a little bit after the
third foot hit ball came out it was a
fumble at that point it was recovered by
the ravens
that's what the ultimate ruling was
after replay review and i talked to john
harbaugh about it after the game that
among many other things he's always a
great uh a great listen after especially
after a win maybe not so much after a
loss but
he saw it in real time and he's like
that's an incompletion and then he looks
up on the
big screen at lucas oil stadium and he
sees and he thinks wait a minute yeah
possession right three feet
holy crap that's an interception yeah so
you know you talk to the people in your
headset that give you advice and as sean
payton has said from time to time those
people get very quiet when it's really
close
but when harbaugh said yeah that's a cat
they all agreed he threw the red flag
and now riveron agreed and and again
does it scream out it's an interception
does it pass that just kind of like know
it when you see it it didn't seem like
he had it long enough but what they did
when they changed the standard a few
years ago they made that third foot
sufficient objective evidence to
complete the act so you have two hands
on the ball and you take three steps
that's it it's a catch or the case may
be an interception so i've come around
on this one i think it was the right
call yeah i i i have a hard time with it
you know it looks like the real right
call because we all we do is see it in
super slow motion now
you know and again i understand the
three-step rule i still thought i don't
know i wasn't sold in on the first two
steps total possession was made there i
just go back to clear and obvious on the
field it wasn't was it that clear and
obvious that it was a interception no
it's not because you know there's 50
non-drunks in an nbc production room
yesterday and most of them didn't think
it was an interception so that that to
me is where i don't get it i i don't and
listen we might as well hit that and a
similar play happened in the arizona
miami game hang on hang on let's hear
from philip rivers before okay sorry i'm
getting excited who clearly disagrees
with the ultimate assessment that was
made
it's gotten so
really jacked up of how the catch role
is i mean nobody that's played
any amount of football or that has been
around the game watched that and thought
it was a catch
including the guy that
dropped it
um
but you know you can slow it down a
milliseconds and you can just make it a
technicality about three feet touch the
ground even though you know you know
somebody that's sitting back watching
this probably hadn't thrown a football
in his life he has to call it so
wow
wow hey little i think i'll river on i
think our riverrun is throwing a
football but here's the thing this was
an automatic review john harbaugh yeah
that was a thing or two about football
right saw it
understands the rules
and realizes even though in real time it
didn't look like a catch
too and
chris i'm telling you because i went
through this yesterday because what they
do is they post the video
al riveron narrates and he says all the
perfunctory checks the box stuff like
well we've two there's possession and
three it's like you try to tune that out
and just watch it if you watch it enough
times it's like hey wait wait
he's got two hands on the ball
and it's one two three and then the ball
starts coming out that's
even though it didn't feel like it
even though it didn't look like it
they've defined the catch
to be possession and if you get that
third step
that's it isn't he you know going to the
ground though i mean that's right i just
don't matter anymore it doesn't matter
anymore yeah i don't know oh they got
rid of all that going to the ground crap
you don't have to survive the ground as
they like to say you just you get three
steps down
they because what they tried they
struggled for years to come up with a
standard yeah i know it's time it would
match objective and subjective the
subjective know it when you see it it's
a catch in my heart at the gut level i
know it's a catch let's come up with a
standard that brings the two together i
think our point here
if there is one is that we've identified
an example of a situation where
objectively right it's a catch
subjectively we look at it and we say
that's not a catch
objectively though it is and that's all
that matters no i i i you're right and i
think you know again
i don't like it i don't think it's a
catch
but
i think
you're right at some point they have to
make something to say okay this is what
it means to subjectively have that catch
and the three-step thing is about as
good as you get and uh yep it is what it
is i just that's to me it's a tough one
either way it was a good football game
as we saw that was a big part of the
football game because the colts were
winning at that moment you know not that
they were controlling but
it was the ravens who had just gotten a
really long drive
fumbled the ball down there close right
with the gus edwards fumble
and you went whoa wow i mean the colts
might get out of this let's see what
happens and then that was the second
play of that drive interception set up a
short field ravens go down square and
that really put them in the position of
power to where they never relinquished
that from there on out and uh fun fun
game to watch but good for the baltimore
ravens good for john harbaugh as you
brought up he's always on top of it is
for the most part as far as game
management's concerned he's as good as
it gets in football
let me ask you this yeah as it relates
to being on the wrong side of a call
like that we saw how upset philip rivers
was after the game when you're in a
situation like that and you feel like
you get screwed during a game how hard
is it as a player to set it aside or
does it just keep bothering you man i
see i'm still upset about i mean how do
you process that emotion and forget
about it and move on yeah no it's one of
those things where it could affect the
next drive and as i'm sitting here i'm
going back to go look at i'm going you
know what did they do the next drive and
as i said here they went through and out
that can be yeah you sit there and
instead now when you're watching the
ravens offense go down the field you're
still thinking about you know and i'm
going to do phillip gosh jolly g george
how did they call that interception you
know he's not looking at his big damn al
riveron gosh jolly g he's never thrown a
pass in his life before he's in new york
sitting all pretty you know what i mean
so that that's where it can be a little
bit distracting that way um but instead
of grabbing the microsoft surface
that's i mean at least in my experience
now philip rivers is a legend and maybe
he's smarter than me to be able to
compar compartment uh you know what i'm
saying get get that out i know what
you're saying compartmentalize
[Laughter]
mvp award that's my next one and here
look
he loves plays forever he loves them not
no no he loves them
i love dalvin cook i don't know about
the rest of the team right now but
what dalvin cook is doing is spectacular
and i think back to adrian peterson in
2012 where peterson made that late
second half push and just started just
going crazy and ultimately won the mvp
award
if the vikings can work their way
somehow into the playoffs and it's not
going to be easy when you look at the
upcoming schedule bingo
there are plenty of winds dotting the
landscape they could get and tarico was
trying to get me to take the bait
yesterday because officially my position
is the annulment papers have been filed
between me and the vikings uh but tariq
was like hey you know they could be
seven and five and when you look at the
schedule they can be seven and five
after starting one in five and dalvin
cook is the reason 226 yards from
scrimmage last week
252 this week six touchdowns he's only
the third guy in nfl history to have 225
yards from scrimmage or more and two
touchdowns or more in consecutive weeks
joining jim brown and deuce mcallister
he matched emmett smith for at least one
rushing touchdown in each of the first
seven games of a season that's the only
two who have ever done that he's got 12
rushing touchdowns in seven games that's
third all-time for the first seven games
of the season
when he plays
and and you know the first two games for
the vikings they were trying to find
their way offensively yeah right they
locked in on cook after week two when
they gave the titans everything they
could handle when all of a sudden the
vikings felt like they could be
competitive
and cook other than the injury other
than the because he got the groin injury
in the third quarter of the seahawks
game he was on pace for another 100 yard
plus from scrimmage game 130 yards
rushing he would have had
he's been spectacular since week three
and as they get into the second half of
the season if he can keep that up you
know we're we're looking at all these
quarterbacks as mvp candidates let's not
rule out a guy
who
and they never give you a definition for
what it means to be mvp
he clearly yes is the most valuable
player on the vikings because without
him they'd be possibly one and seven or
one eight no i mean he's he's a special
football player and you know they they
do they got a chance to go on a run
but it's amazing first off how talented
he is and then it shows
you know the
the run game intelligence and coaching
of gary kubiak once again i mean he's
just amazing that way how he can
continue week by week him rick dennison
who's up there have been a longtime
friend and coaching partner of him where
they can find
these ways and these different schemes
on a week-to-week basis to kind of crack
the code of every defense where you go
they know the first thing they have to
do is stop calvin cook yet doesn't
matter he finds ways to do it and you
know they once they get that going and
kubiak's so good at finding ways to get
it going through his years with shanahan
and everything that's when you know hey
justin jefferson feeling the play action
passes and screens become alive and they
really got you once they got you at that
point but man is he something to watch
his acceleration through the hole is as
good as anybody in football and then you
know he has a long speed to just outrun
people too it's rare that he has that
type of acceleration and the type of
speed to go on a 70 yard touchdown but
minnesota hanging tough really got a lot
of respect for them mike zimmer
everything he's doing you know they've
had some tough losses but here they are
at three and five and just as florio
wanted to get out they pull them back in
and they go no you are not leaving our
vikings fandom quite yet and you're not
allowed to jump back on the bandwagon if
they get in the playoffs this year i'm
not letting it happen just so you know
you're off okay that's fine you're done
it's fine
i'm not letting you go back okay
that's fine because my son continues to
be on the bandwagon and he will be happy
and you know as a parent all you really
want is for your kids to be happy yeah i
i get that yes that's so sweet what a
good daddy you are all right um i think
i want to give the st stay the hell out
of the way award to the chicago bears
offense as my next superlative just stay
the hell out of the way okay
just you know try to do something
positive every now and then and let your
defense play please because i mean it's
just it's every week they find a way
they're offense it's just so ugly and
crappy and i know they hung around
yesterday you know with the tennessee
titans with a lot of late yards and you
know some points that way but man can
that offense they can't do anything i
mean they really can't it's just there's
no imagination there's no toughness you
know they seem to have a bad turnover
every week and they got this great
defense who can just about stop anybody
but
they
do them an injustice by always giving
turnover short field not being able to
stay on the field that way i mean that
was an ugly game yesterday it was there
to be had tennessee wasn't exactly
clicking on all cylinders they were
struggling that bear's defense was all
over derrick henry ryan tannehill they
couldn't find anything to do but man
bears offense can't do anything they
can't make any plays and okay if you're
gonna be like that that's fine but stop
making plays of the other team i mean
that's the thing they've continually
done the last few weeks and
it's a super bowl defense and it's a
crap offense and i don't know where it
goes with the bears you can see they can
play with just about anybody because of
that defense and they find a way to
screw it up a lot
all right which oh wait yeah i was gonna
say yeah that was mine it's mine it was
mine that was nice
i agree stay the hell out of the way and
the bears host the vikings next monday
night which you know last uh last night
yesterday afternoons game between the
vikings and the lions was for third
place in the division now here comes the
second place game not that anybody's
going to catch the packers but the
vikings could find a way to maybe thrust
themselves into the conversation for a
wild card berth if they could keep this
up next one for me this is the cool hand
looting award i gotta give jake gluten a
little love especially since i called
him luke jayton all week hey right out
of the gates long touchdown pass for the
jacksonville jaguars maybe they're gonna
to surprise the texans yesterday and
they took it down to the wire there was
a 13-yard touchdown run by jake lewton
to make it a two-point game they failed
to tie it up with the two-point
conversion and the jacksonville jaguars
ultimately lost but they got something
in jake lewton just like they had
something a year ago in gardner minshew
and with minshu with the fractures in
his thumb
maybe you let it ride with jake luke you
know maybe maybe jake lewton saves jobs
this year the way gardner minshew saved
some jobs last year chris well it was a
good start nonetheless we'll see where
it goes i would i would think he gets
you know another opportunity with with
minshew's you know availability and the
broken
bones in his hands and everything like
that but you know saw some of these
things when he came out of oregon state
in college you know he's got great
control of the football
very lo you know very rarely is off
target you know he's a decent athlete as
we saw on the touchdown run at the end
of the game to get the game close spin
move in the end zone but smart
and it's a good arm it's not a great arm
but he can make all the throws certainly
and he's got good size there's a lot to
like about what he brings to the table
now i don't know if he's franchise
starting quarterback i'd like to see a
little bit more there but either way
that was an impressive start for him
definitely and hey while we're at it i
mean we just got to talk about desean
watson too he's damn good too you know
the texans are not a real good football
team but he continues to play like he's
one of the 10 best quarterbacks in the
game we got we can you know he's going
to get lost in the shuffle this year but
he's still really damn good and made a
handful of plays yesterday himself
yeah it's just a shame that uh that he's
on a team where
they they
they just don't have enough help around
him and that should be a very attractive
head coaching job i know they don't have
their first or second round pick next
year thanks to the larry mutunsel and
kenny stills trade but you've got desean
watson and
they fired bill o'brien five weeks ago
six weeks ago now hopefully they're
taking full advantage of this time to
identify the best candidate to come in
and get the most out of
out of desean watson because he deserves
to have a better team around him chris
yeah no he he does he definitely does
and yeah they got some work cut out for
them so they got a lot of stuff to
figure out in that organization and then
they can start to get that roster going
on the right track um what is it mine or
yours this is this is mine right here we
go you did cool hand looting one more
for you one more for you if you got one
i mean lightning strikes again i mean we
haven't talked about the chargers and
usually it's the chargers blowing leads
and then the other team winning but here
was a case where chargers came back
raiders had chances to put them away
chargers get the ball one more time here
comes justin herbert down the field
man
i mean two plays in the end zone
uh mike williams goes up the first time
on third down and then on on fourth down
it was uh was it pull him am i am i
getting his name right there yeah par
him parham excuse me
he just misses a catch and a one-on-one
ball at the end there but
wow i mean first off there's the raiders
good job by them once again running the
ball well derek carr was pretty
efficient for the most part of the day
but
the chargers just cannot figure out how
to win a football game at the end it's
unbelievable whether it's closing it out
or coming back
there is just an element of their team
that is missing that way that they can't
seem to come come through in these 50 50
type games
and uh you're absolutely right they're
two and six the best two and six team uh
around which isn't much of a consolation
and uh they've they've they've
definitely
broken new ground with the whole face
covering thing this is a chargers coach
from yesterday oh i saw that take it to
break that's that's a pair of shorts
that's that's a pair of shorts he's got
a hook on there i can see it it's not a
pair of shorts there's a hook around his
ear
it's uh well maybe that's the string
it's a pair of shorts or and which is
fitting because earlier this year when
the raiders played the patriots john
gruden wore a loincloth over his face so
uh if you're going to go with with you
know who that is or any
who i can't it's a special teams coach
he used to play linebacker for the the
broncos back in the day i'm blanking on
his damn name and it's killing me so you
don't know who it is either no but i
know you know who it is and i know who
it is i can't find it out and that's
killing me here
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports